let me show you how to approach this now
when you think about it you know you can
let the repayment the regular repayment
be P right but at least if you look at
this line here you run into a problem
okay because you think well okay if this
is my variable where do I stick it right
do you remember when we simplify power
okay um the value we had for paper for
10,000 okay it actually mixed in with
the other values that we have in the
question so it turns out that this line
even though it's nice and simple doesn't
what's not very useful for this kind of
question so I actually have to go back a
couple of lines go back to a on a form
of the question which had piece still
preserved in it and then I can put that
in as an unknown okay so how far do I
have to go back I have to come back to a
of n what do we say there was the 50,000
at the start right okay and that have
been applied well if there's any years
and lots of interests right okay and
then what happened over here well we
subtracted and then we got the series
right and there was the 10,000 out the
front and there's the value interested
in actually finding okay there's the
unknown and then after that I've got my
series right
what was the series it was one four one
five okay so there's a form I can
actually use now since he wants to repay
in five years I want a five to the key
to zero right
so therefore I can actually get some
values so I can say 0 should be equal to
50 grand by 1.15 to the five minus
okay it's a bit of calculating work
right
once I've rearranged I'm gonna get pay
as the subjects I guess I can move it
over and then I can cross multiply all
right so once I move it over it'll be
here one after I cross multiply
I'll have 50,000 1.15 205 and this is my
cross multiplication step okay now who's
got another for you there
okay so she is what I prepared oh yeah
it's it's just under 15 grand and I
think like 78 cents or something okay so
this is the amount he has to repay
almost 50% more in order to make back in
five years now just to finish I'm
suppose it says that's ridiculous that's
exorbitant this is a really bad deal
I do want to pay off in five years but I
can't make that venue repayment okay so
the bank very charitably it says to you
okay par the reason this is so bad is
because you pay us so seldom you make
its way to year before you pay us back
right to actually far more common in
these questions repent on monthly
installments for instance I pay my
mortgage off in stores so here's the
question I posed to you I'll show you
the solution on Monday okay if I keep
everything the same in terms of how much
is borrowed what the interest rate is
how quickly he wants to repay it but
adjusted so that it's all monthly
instead of okay so that means number one
he repays my client number two they
charge interests monthly here's my
question how much would he save in turn
how much will he stay unit to save money
same interest the same time all these
changed is how often he pays and how
often they calculate interest how much
did you save in the